how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have some news about the MCU growing
a little bit bigger
obviously with Avengers in game ending
the first ten years story arc of the MCU
and phase three phase four will start
not too long after with spider-man far
from home and now along with the movies
we will have some shows that exist in
and effect the MCU as well
now we've had MCU TV shows in the past
that have connected to the film's but
not really it's really just been the
movies that have affected what happens
in the shows and the shows had really no
impact on anything that's happened in
the MCU films but according to Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
these shows will affect what we see in
the MCU films I'll talk about what he
said about these shows in this video but
quick reminder about my IMAX ticket
giveaway giving away five imax tickets
so you and some friends can go see
Avengers in-game in IMAX or Captain
Marvel if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain I'll be picking a winner on
Sunday March 3rd ok so if you haven't
heard Disney is coming out with their
own streaming service Disney Plus said
to release at the end of this year and
with Disney plus we will get exclusive
Marvel shows we're supposed to get a
Loki show a vision and Scarlet Witch
show and a Bucky and Falcon show and
since all of these characters that will
be appearing in these upcoming shows are
technically dust right now
people have been wondering if they're
actually linked to the MCU well the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
actually came out and told us himself in
a recent interview when asked about the
shows Kevin Feige said it will be MCU
proper sometimes it will take place as
Captain Marvel did in a time before
current events sometimes it will take
place during what I will say whatever
happens in those and those shows and
with characters that have been in the
films they'll undergo transformations
not Loki necessarily but will undergo
transformations in their series and
those transformations will be reflected
in their next film appearances because
we've been developing long-form
narrative stories for Disney Plus at the
exact same time that we've been
developing a post Avengers
game MCU we've been able to do something
we've never done before which is
interweave them from the start from the
plant so this is big news the MCU just
got a lot bigger with all these shows
coming out and more to come this isn't
going to be like agents of shield where
the movies effect a show but the show
doesn't affect the movie they've been
developing what Kevin Feige calls
long-form narrative stories at the same
exact time that they've been developing
a post Avengers in-game emcee which
includes spider-man far from home Doctor
Strange - the Black Widow movie and so
on so essentially what Kevin Feige is
saying here is that these shows will be
in the next phase of the MCU this is
such great news because there is so much
more potential for great stories in the
MCU now Marvel only likes to release two
maybe three films a year but since these
shows will be connected to the MCU the
MCU will continue to develop between the
movies so we will no longer have to wait
months and months to see what the MCU is
doing so let me know what you think
about the MCU expanding with these shows
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers and Game Disney Plus and Marvel
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]